not everybody happy with President Trump
abandoning the Paris climate Accord it's
like a children show the planets warming
up no it's true people not happy about
this in protest of President Trump
abandoning the Paris climate Accord the
CEO of Disney has resigned from Trump's
Business Advisory Council see you a
business whose I resign
yeah you know folks it's not a good sign
when a company led by a giant talking
mouse is telling the president to be
more realistic you're like in a fantasy
world this guy
it's science buddy a mouse with four
fingers speaking of Fantasyland the
number one movie in the country is
Wonder Woman it'd be over
yeah very exciting over the weekend this
is historic the Wonder Woman will be
shattered the glass ceiling breaking 100
million dollars in box office say in
fact in fact the only way Wonder Woman
could have done better as if she had
campaigned in Wisconsin and then she
would have won the whole thing
oh come on just think about it a little
bit you don't have to be happy about it
these are free of course like you not
everyone happy about Wonder Woman
several panelists on Fox News accused
Wonder Woman of not being American
enough because her costume isn't red
white and blue yeah they're also saying
to really be American it should be a
double XL because
[Applause]
in Michigan was I doing cats or bullets
that's what a by note I was trying to do
bullets here was a part of the movie
where they throw kittens I write that
Nazi kitten gun Nazi kitten gun in
Michigan a Republican congressman said
that God would take care of climate
change yeah so now a group of polar
bears are on their way to take care of a
Republican congressman my polar bear
rolls up his sleeve worried I'm an idiot
big news for Apple fans you probably
heard about this today 15 new features
were revealed about the upcoming iPhone
8 the biggest new feature is the battery
that only lasts until the announcement
of the iPhone 9
now please that was plenty that was I
had aplenty I had enough to legally
proceed I'm good a new study this is
crazy new study claims that popular
people may live longer than unpopular
people yeah
plays dumbing if that's true Shia
LaBeouf died in 1982 and me in 1988 you
laughed too hard sir
you